walkabouts come with me Josh Smith and
today we are joined by rebel Wilson
well today seems you're the start of the
hustle I want to get a lesson in
hustling okay from you so I have a
couple of scenarios that I want you to
talk me free basic okay you're basically
my agony on okay in a lesson how to fake
air bases yeah okay so I suspect my man
is up to no good
oh how can I hustle to find out the
truth what tips would you give me steal
their phone cracker when they're in the
shower in the toilet or something
get that phone go through it we're not
above that look at who they follow on
Instagram and like what photos they've
liked if they've liked a certain
person's photo you're like hang on how
who is that person you go deep diving on
the Instagram smell them right just get
up close smell them see if you can smell
any other sense of any other people like
a human sniffer dog place yeah yeah they
try to do it subtly yeah so they don't
know you're doing in are you doing it
you could always just ask the person you
just round just beyond are you cheating
on me like just tell me just straight up
yeah I like that but we also like the
dirty methods yeah yeah for sure yeah I
need to call my boss into thinking I
need to leave work for an emergency but
naturally it's for happy hour yeah yeah
yeah yeah what free climbing tips could
you get me to target those heartstrings
I would never wanting courage like
outright lying like oh my grandmother's
had a stroke like you know I don't I
don't think you know you don't want to
wish that on people some people say you
should just say oh I'm so sorry I have
to go and then you don't actually give a
reason yeah that's like the new thing
mm-hmm you do like it's my dog I have to
go
oh you know blame it on a pet yes at
least they're not a person yeah that's
the good part
yeah or just be like oh my god oh my god
I have to go and don't tell Dana don't
tell the reason it's a good hustler
someone who tells the truth
and yes Flavor Flav stretches and
stretches it a little bit now I feel
like my camp British accent isn't
necessarily the best thing to use for a
hustle what accent do you think would be
the most effective for a good darn good
hustle see I think it's a trust whatever
a trust where the accent is and I
actually think the British accent is
quite trust with em cuz of like the
Queen's English
you know you trust the Queen wouldn't
you yeah it's that kind of voice could
be quite trustworthy what other country
would you trust I guess Spencer land but
maybe Australia Australians might be
touchy because people think are we're
too dumb to like scam anybody so maybe
this Traian accent could work too now
finally I wanna pull up a hustle but my
wardrobe says more body con than con
artists what styling tips can you give
me Josh you like super stylish already
oh my god stop it look at that hair C is
very hard to do you're very lucky to
have that hair I would say work it like
it fluff it up like you know not many
guys have hair like that you've been
amazing thank you so much thanks Jimmy
you